chi vota riguarda
se dietro
benvenuti il solito stai sono vestiti di
blu
proveremo
perché se ne sono tantissimi infatti se
questo video raggiunge i 10 mila mi
piace faremo una seconda parte in cui
proviamo tutti gli altri giochi robles
di maki white prende tipo accordo
mettetevi comode iniziamo subito ecco
qua il primo gioco poi alla fine del
quale il gioco che vi è piaciuto più di
tutti di questi di a chi oa che allora
c'era più equa però è fermo penso che
dobbiamo scappare in questo labirinto
già parlando è incastrato quale la beta
ma forse dobbiamo andare da questa parte
seconda vita e anche qui a luoghi ok
questi una kiwan chi no fermo fermo
anche se sia una macchina di santa rosa
no non è quella siamo quindi questo
primo gioco è una sorta di labirinto
capo da chivu non eroi che si sta
spostandosi bene date da dio non farti
prendere ma se riusciremo resovia
passare se vedete anche il mio personale
per la vestito tutto di bluvia
nostra stella da evitare avevo detto di
spostarlo se non avete visto il video in
cui giochiamo copy playtime che sarebbe
appunto sono antiquati andate a vederlo
dopo questo video perché abbiamo
commentato
allora sono riuscito a superarlo sto
arrivando beh io ormai sono dentro il
labirinto che vi trovano devo riuscire a
pensare alla fine della di rito prima di
vitale
chissà se ciò che uscirà senza dei posti
mi sto per raggiungere davvero forse non
mi vede d'acqua no è un vicolo cieco
sbagliato o meno piacere i labirinti ne
perdo sempre
ci siamo incontrati per sbaglio
e allora ecco che viene eliminato
qualcuno da quello che ho potuto vedere
qui non c'è una via d'uscita nome non
c'è una via d'uscita a chi è unatras ha
chiuso non si va da nessuna parte ma
anche senza avere un labirinto la via
d'uscita
forse siamo noi che non riusciamo a
trovarla eccolo c'è qualcosa qui finisce
una luce verde forse siamo riusciti a
trovare l'uscita è proprio questa strana
aspetta non ci dividiamo
e questo era il primo gioco non troviamo
la via destinerà è non so se c'è davvero
una via d'uscita quindi passiamo al
prossimo presso mangiato questo è come
il gioco originale poppi playtime però
l'hanno ricreato tutto il robot
guardante è uguale lei non proprio
uguale ovviamente quella originale più
bello perché a molti più dettagli molte
più cose allora qui c'è il treno ha
creato quasi
de rosa giallorosso uguale vi ricordate
non so perché c'è questa inquadratura
strana che mi posso muovere così non
vedo il mio personaggio è vitale non è
riuscito a entrare ma solo un giocatore
ma vediamo se funziona soprattutto
vediamo che arriva ai maghi anche nvidia
hanno disegnato un po
amaro
ecco qua
è strano vedere lo stesso gioco però
fatto il rosa dove dovevo andare adesso
se riuscite a passare a khimki rob lotto
poi devo dire che è anche carino
senza che apra la bocca forniamo 14 file
di 20 e anche carino ti saluta però poi
una volta che vi muoverlo
gay
la canzone ufficiale di marijuana
l'abbiamo spedita anche nell'altro gioco
praticamente penso che sia siccome alpi
luoghi doveva essere un giocattolo
sempre un pupazzo se veniva venduto nei
negozi di giocattoli
sicuramente nella pubblicità davano
questa canzone l'avranno mai venduto agi
gis adesso che ci penso da tempo oppure
no aprica l'hanno chiusa prima se avete
visto il video presidente sapete che
l'esperimento è andato un po male è vero
come sembra una canzone così allegra
divertente invece poi lui è mortale ma
qui bisogna collegare che faccio una
presa di corrente in uscita ce l'abbiamo
fatta abbiamo passato tutte le messe
devo dire che a chi va chi sta per
arrivare spirito è
sparito allora adesso si è aperta
un'altra porta immagino che tenda ad
entrare qui non vedo l'ora di vedere
come hanno realizzato la parte in cui
kapidani guardi nella fabbrica corridoio
ortigia qua
erano già stati vapore ma ricorda
adesso perfetta gialla la casetta gialla
era più in là vero ma bisogna prendere
tutti i colori ecco quello i blu ei come
faccio a prenderlo ok tutti i colori che
ho trovato mi manca il blu ma non riesco
a prenderlo dal lingotto riuscire a
prendere il gruppo sopra lo vedete ma
non si arriva
mai preso prova l'ho preso a quindi
bisognava saltare porto
e crociati asteniamo allora briga è è un
baldo porta l'altra mano lavano rossa
proprio ricreato tutto e ora andiamo
alla fabbrica dei giocattoli
ti ricordi la strada qual'era adesso
bisogna solo cliccare per attivare le
tristezze di quell'altro che dio tirare
tutti i fili ecco qua l'ultimo da
arrivare grazie a parlare le pubblicità
e così quando ha pubblicato
ricreato vediti macchinari e lì bisogna
attivare l'elettricità però prima
brava a salire su ovvero abbiamo
l'elettricità bisogna attivare testimone
e poi arriverà a maghi
eccola è attiva si sentono che è andato
lì devo prendere il giocattolo che
dovrebbe uscire da qua eccolo strati
vando che carino ne prendi la radio è
appreso è dovuto mettere uno scanner me
siete pronti a vedere come è stato
realizzato nei laghi con lo scanner del
controllo qualità sta controllando
perfetta verso la porta questo il
momento in cui arriva andiamo abbiamo
qui si è preso per carino si
è posta come la porta vediamo se
riusciremo a scappare ma lui non è
entrato abbiamo tardi matias ogni b che
strano che questa musica mi fa venire
l'ansia da cerchiamo il tunnel giusto
adesso eccola lì lo vedi turn e river o
no ma non è bloccato nilo vedete è
bloccato nelle mele grave non può
prendermi d'acqua e sicura
strisciando ma forse sta passando da di
qua adesso ti prende mai chiuso la
destra perfetto allora per fortuna e
mette dove devo andare
eccolo è rimasto bloccato
perché sei andato da lui
perché sono sottoterra negli ingranaggi
che succede
questa esperienza sei morto codice
errore gioco allora quello di prima ha
detto vi è un impatto perché non abbiamo
fatto riprovare ma la star morta solo
disconnesso e questo prossimo gioco
indagini
al di la di ob quindi
napoli si percorre via a chivu anche
laggiù gigante velocissimo non sa fare
tanto la quante volte si straccerà o
bella questa scacchiera non vedo l'ora
di vedere vitale che cade no anche
perché stiamo in alto quindi mi farei un
super volo è ma non si muove anche maghi
forse che bella questa scala gigante
per evitare assolutamente
che bella questa
guardo da qui si vede dai giochi no
vabbè si placa scompare se non
conquistano scomparse cosa qua ti
aspetto in finale dai sbrigati
che fatto
così stragelato che diventa
vitale non ci credo
non cambieremo gioco coppie vitale non
si sfracella solo sfracellato un bambino
però mai fatto se non vedo niente ti si
è sfracellato pure tu
nella porta giusta giallo poi verde
verde arancio
ecco vita è troppo alti devo superarla
wow siamo o no
non ci credo che mi sono sfracellata più
volte di evitare come posti che risale
super avanti tra l'altro dai sbrigati
a picco vaghi luoghi da dietro cappello
quello scivolo intanto davanti
non dovevo saltare dentro il cerchio
dovevo andare intorno
prossimo gioco
forse anche qua non ricreato il gioco
originale
l'altro fatto molto mesi si è fatto su
per bene quasi meglio di quello
originale e quindi questo immagino che
sarà il gioco normale che ormai lo
conosciamo prossimo gioco
questo si chiama fuoco il play time
software to capitolo 2 ma ovviamente non
sarà il vero cameri no perché ancora non
cito vediamo che cosa si sono inventati
li amo ma sei tu questo no io sono
questo mi sento non metterti qua perché
non cammino nemmeno spiaccicata
dall'alto
andiamo avanti
spero di non rimanere a
milano
sono un terno
bisogna colpire chi quasi ma io sono già
antigua di ome non farà niente così come
lo è stata lo trovate le firme l'abbiamo
preso forse
merito quello che mi stava sparando no
io sono qua che striscia
mi sta colpendo capitale io devo cercare
qualcosa
visto che ce l'avevamo già
e sono in cucina la mia arma fluttua c'è
anche un macchinoso che mi sta
inseguendo rotta qui dietro di perdere
no non dove sei tu non so dove devo
andare in tutte le due scale non vi
trovo più dove siete
io mi sono nascosto appena una stanza
forse devo scendere quando ho finalmente
vi ha ritrovato si stanno eseguendo
eccolo a chi ma che lo vede quello rosa
c'è anche quella rosa per durata
dovrebbe essere la sua fidanzata
veramente che è successo mi ha
cancellato ma che bello sono tornata io
normale di una deriva v6 eccomi ai ma
sono in due
vicinissimo
barabba
poi volendo per morire
no stanno porta io no avete eliminato
quello rossa no quello quello blu come
si chiama quella rosa se l'avete scarico
madoff in l'altro video treno mi ricordo
come si chiamava ok howett zizzi quasi
zanzi
fidanzato senso che ora sia ancora più
arrabbiato ma kimwaki perché abbiamo
eliminato la sua fidanzata attenta
dietro di te ma quante volte sono porta
grandezza e ancora neanche una volta
quindi
penso che ne escano altri di continuo a
volte abbiamo fatto dei punti quindi
siamo eliminati
eccolo laggiù attenta sfruttati dalle
scale quanti molti ho fatto io ho fatto
3.600 23.800 punti perché se questo vela
yacht o anche ma che mi sta inseguendo
no ma non è possibile che non sei ancora
tanto fragile che non ti avvicini
propria dagli wine può essere eliminato
io ho fatto anche 4.125 punti vabbè io
esplora un po la casa nel primo ok
andiamo
presente la libreria strada sotto nel
sotterraneo è come ci sono anch'io
faccio una prigione forse si può
chiudere a chi poi qua dentro e d'acqua
che non amando credo che sia scappato
proprio da lì che c'è qualcuno ciao sede
è questo se qualcuno nascosto
e
juve dove risuonano e battere anche i
quali fatidica appoggiarti sta facendo
un sacco di punti se si nasconde così
pury più sopravvivi più fai frontini età
c'è un passaggio qua vediamo questa se
vediamo un passaggio segreto
siamo
qua siamo risaliti sopra un arresto a
passare da quanto traspare però c'è una
chiave blu qui la vede un interessante
prendiamo la
ripresa ma cosa ci servirà qua non si
apre niente non si apre quello no
altrimenti non c'è che cosa faceva più
noto riguarda che succede perché così
clicca stata nel muro abbiamo potuto di
punti c'è scritto aiutatemi nel muro
shakuhachi rosa prima casa ma perché può
sempre qua già preso il volo
lo scopo ciao e ora come faccio a
ritrovare quel passaggio segreto o
quasi scendo assorto nuovo pure lei
scendeva sotto attento a fi attento ti
segue da qui non può passare
neanche quello lì nascosto in
quell'angolo mi aiutano se vai con sotto
lui non può passare a un certo punto si
blocca e quindi da pirlo poi eliminare
ecco vitale e come li minuto anche vaghi
rotta dai scopriamo dove quella porta
cioè ancora la chiave non lo so ma è
sparita pensi mì attenta f potrebbe
essercene un altro è ma siamo tornati
all entrata abbiamo qui in cucina dalla
cucina se possiamo andare a volte a
tentare un gol dove in cucina io salgo
sopra ok eccolo no era un giocatore
io sto esplorando sopra però non trovo
niente di meno
servono rinforzi isolato
prossimo gioco di questa volta abbiamo
lo stesso il gioco ricreato quello
originale però finalmente multigiocatore
forse quello che tutti assieme mare la
torcia
cos'è questo
andiamo subito a mettere i colori ormai
come la fa mi amo tutti i passaggi del
gioco dei rumori inquietanti sono gli
altri giocatori ho guardato solo delle
confezioni condizioni robles
sono tutti
con me l'aspettavo che a chi no chi
posteggia quali già preso
no però chi voleva anche quel rumore del
treno
mi ha preso come ti apprezzo prova a
tornare ma come si sta fermando viene da
qua da volando allora proviamo io voglio
scappare in una di queste stesse questo
questa musica fa paura
[Musica]
ma poi ogni tanto si blocca dobbiamo
trovare qualcosa per è un treno a di
tutto devo trovare qualcosa qua per
fermarlo
forse qualche oggetto allora qui c'è un
pulsante rosso ok io sono riuscito a
scappare da dietro al desk che dici di
non entrare qua ma io
sono nel il coach di ventilazione
nell'evento perché lui non arrivi altri
miti tramonti piano io qui vedo degli
altri giocatori ma per fortuna non sono
sola fitch e anche un altro giocatore
qua e arriva adesso io ho preso mi viene
un infarto e proprio dietro di terna
scappa scappa scappa scappa non c'è
nessuno sì lo abbiamo dato ore ma preso
proprio li aiuto sei riuscita è stato
questo mandato accendi la luce che luce
il numero uno vai di avere la pila e ora
dovremo andare io seguo questo giocatore
che ha preso di nuovo ma come mai non
c'è invece perché se questo hotel
non lo so brood sempre o no sono rimasto
da solo mi ha cambiato strada
che va da sola ecco il rischio che
arrivi anche maghi può essere che
proprio lì vicino a te
seguiamo lui forse saprà dove andare
speriamo
e dietro e
davanti a te sarà l'ultimo giovedì a di
luoghi scriveteci nei commenti qual è
stato il vostro preferito e lasciate un
mi piace siamo
qualificare provvedere inoltre altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite
buona visione